it's wonderful to be here with you I've
been dying to be on your show I'm so
honored that you would come here and you
know you have been such a part of our
Lives I don't know
what a lot of my life would be without
it's so much more than a show it's our
growing up it's our development it's our
cultural references
um I mean I will quote the show every
day of my life you know I definitely
feel that we were just
um so thrilled to be in it and I don't
know that we really realized the larger
ramifications for a long time you know
you're just kind of in it and we knew
that we loved it you know we knew that
we were so devoted to it and we loved
our characters and we loved our arcs we
never knew quite was what was going to
happen and obviously shooting here in
the city was like such a huge part of it
and I think when you're in it you don't
realize the ramification sometimes so
you can step out or get a little
distance yeah and then I would say that
that when the show ended is one time
that I was really
um bowled over and overwhelmed by the
largeness of it all because people would
come up to me and cry and I'm relatively
good that makes me feel a lot better
because you came out like I might cry I
know it's adorable but I mean you then
I'm very close to crying too because I'm
not very different from you so then
we'll all cry together but that's okay
we love our feelings and I feel so like
incredibly grateful to be a part of it
and Incredibly grateful to be coming
back it's it's kind of a small miracle
oh my God the reboot is exactly what we
need but we're not calling it a reason I
was going to say when you're not calling
it The matriculation that's right we're
calling it the next chapter and just
like that was for fans a no-brainer
that's what Carrie would write in her
column right and that's what we said
when Miranda had her baby and just like
that
Miranda was a mother yeah
yeah I mean these friendships that
developed to be told as women which I
always loved you know that your
girlfriends are everything that your
friendships are that family are the what
if I had never met you guys moment I've
said that to my friends I've told my
friends to not stop doing what you know
I know I know when you said to like him
to set the date I look up beautiful
alongside of you not to be pushy and to
let go and learn and also to love
yourself you know
right because that's really what's
underneath it don't you think like I I
think for myself
one of the things and and Charlotte
obviously has a whole journey that's
very different from my own even though
people of course think I'm Charlotte
witches it's a compliment I get it but
you know I'm not necessarily following
the same tract as her but I think the
biggest lesson from her that I learned
and from all of us is you know you have
this idea you have this ideal and you're
trying so hard to live up to your ideal
of what your life should look like and
when you should do things and how you
should do things and what they should
look like and that isn't really how life
works I always wanted to be a Charlotte
I was a Samantha
and I think you were a little Carrie
come on and I was super caring thank you
okay great because and you're wearing
your flowers but I yes absolutely yes
but then I became the truest Charlotte I
know and now the beautiful wallpaper I
mean so many things I really did I
married Someone who lived on people I
said yes and then I I think now at this
point I might be very Miranda like super
Miranda you wait till you see this show
I can't wait because I'm gonna check
back in Drew we have grown up with and
we continue to grow and it's been a
moment since the movies and the show and
we'll see where things are at now wait
is it true that you get in a fight with
a main character is this a rumor that I
mean I said the word fight and then I
thought oh gosh that was a terrible
mistake to say that word it's not a
fight I didn't mean that it's a conflict
it's an emotional conflict with one of
our our best friends and it's so so
deeply uncomfortable in the moment
filming the scene was so deeply deeply
deeply uncomfortable and I went to
Michael Patrick King our you know
executive producer writer writer lover
of all kinds yes Guru in the beginning
exactly and he was directing
and I said Michael
it's too
well and he was like yes I
know and I was like no no no
I have to we have to shift it I can't be
here he was like yes you can this is why
I wrote it for you it's bespoke writing
I can't wait to see who it's with well
get ready honey
I'm ready I'm so excited there's a lot
coming I mean I just saw the first three
and I'm still processing and I had
obviously read the script and been there
when we were filming it and I'm still
processing it's a lot it's it's it's
deep and also funny I can't wait I'm so
excited I'm glad I hope you like it I
hope I haven't given anything away
because I will be in so much trouble I
know Marvel Universe it's true so come
get me
[Music]
foreign